hallöchen meine lieben freunde und
herzlich willkommen zur siebten folge
von christmas kräftig habe hier immer
noch meinen tollen es die muskeln an den
ich mittlerweile echt schöner finden als
den komischen weihnachtsmann eigentlich
müsste ich den er dann auch noch mal so
komisch aufbauen
nur das habe ich schon überlegt nur was
ich zeige euch das mal ganz kurz nochmal
der zur komische verschiedenen
brauntönen und bei minecraft gibt es in
der branche
deswegen ist das schlecht darzustellen
also das erstmal kurzum das clever
manche leute unter platzecks geschrieben
dass ich ihn doch auch mal darstellen
sollte allerdings auch durch muss ich
noch ganz kurz für platzecks
entschuldigen und zwar hab ich dort
vergessen oben links was ihr gerade
eingeblendet das hab ich vergessen in
part 6 1 zu beenden
das habe ich einfach mit seiner youtube
anmerkung gemacht und zwar hab ich mir
das hier alle schon mit photoshop
mühevoll verarbeitet und dann hab ich's
vergesse reinzuziehen premiere also na
ja heute haben den bau vorschlag von
mini und yuki die mal ich soll einen
riesen schneemann bauen und so ron mz
mit dem vorschlag gemacht wie werde co
wie also spiele wer wie bzw wer
dekoriert bei euch den weihnachtsbaum
wäre nett würdest du dann auf meinen
namen erwähnen also your own in cds der
name windsor
ich hab mir gedacht hat wird er
theoretisch den schneemann
hierhin bauen können war wir haben hier
platz genau hier so da müssen wir noch
mal ganz kurz überlegen was brauche ich
denn alles so für sonn schneemann also
da wir hier so verschiedene dings am
hand übrigens hier schon park ist es
sind nämlich in dem text beck
schneemänner
aber ich denke einfach dass wir das so
machen werden dass wir zu nehmen
hieraus können eventuell das sieht
besser aus finde ich so was schwarzer
wolle machen wir die dings und ihnen den
mund zu optimieren
was können doch machen übrigens habe ich
im hintergrund immer mehr fernseher an
aber ich den also ich hab nen fernseher
an weil ich habe dem so als als ich sag
mal ich das nennen als
wärmequelle für mein zimmer aber dass er
ins kalte ich mir das kommt im fernsehen
und dann läuft auch noch champions
league deswegen kommt mir das alles
recht gelegen
also ich bin einfach mal so gross geht 1
2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
19 20 das heißt bei den hier einfach so
rum warte ich quatsch gleich über das
thema nicht rausnehmen steht nicht mehr
1 2 3 4 5 6 7 8 9 10 11 12 13 14 15 16
17 18 19 20
so also ich könnte natürlich über sachen
reden wie zb dass die beziehung zwischen
angela merkel und diesem anderen
komischen fuzzy der dingsda besucht hat
jetzt nicht so die allerbeste sei weil
das habe ich gerade bei sat 1
nachrichten gesehen aber das
interessiert ja nicht weil uns
interessieren um wichtige themen wie zum
beispiel wer dekoriert bei uns den
weihnachtsbaum
das ist natürlich von aussagekräftig
aber deutschland das ist auf jeden fall
schon mal geradeaus
jetzt überlege ich aber gerade ein
schneemann ist nicht eckig das heißt wir
haben das problem egal ob ich die sache
ist ich glaube ich wollte nicht gerade
ein bisschen groß dabei ist
gott hat wird echt immens groß das heißt
es wird die dann irgendwie so also der
werde zwar nicht so ganz gerade aber ich
sage mal es reicht ja dann wird das
heute wieder eine etwas längere folge
aber wer dekorierte weihnachtsbaum ist
auf jeden fall ein thema wo ich lange
drücken kann
und zwar wie alle zusammen passt ja also
wir haben das so schön dass man da
hinten dass es jetzt so neblig ist ich
hab das mal überhaupt die fans ein
bisschen umgestellt sieht es richtig gut
aus wenn man am hintergrund diese
schneelandschaft hat schon celik naja
optisch fallen hab ich dann sogar glaube
ich mal vorgestellt so als mod vorschlag
also brauchte das ganze einfach auf
einem kanal ob tief ein suchen
berichtete sie zu witzig aus ist mir
richtig richtig schlecht gelungen aber
sie gehen wir und der zeigten die
gazetten sein mittelfinger ok cool so
also dekorieren dekorieren mit seiner
seine sache heißt das jetzt kaufen und
aufstellen und so was alles oder sind
feinde höhere oder heißt es jetzt
allgemein auch so kugeln dran handy etc
bbl dass er dann wieder so die sache
also kugeln dranhängen und so das machen
wir eigentlich alle zusammen beziehungen
haben die andere gemacht ich war als sie
das gemacht habe war ich gerade nicht da
da wollten die extra auf mich warten und
dann kommen sie doch nicht gemacht
aber ja ich bin eigentlich meine sehr
sehr faule person was das angeht das
heißt ich stelle mich dann dahin kommt
meiner schwester dazu wie die das macht
oder meinen eltern oder so und sagt das
macht er gut und hängt da mal noch grün
und blau und ich dirigent das machen
sollen sagt ich mal wenn ich überhaupt
damit helfe aber sonst würde ich
eigentlich sagen was ich war das mal
ganz kurz sodass sie gehen wie cool aus
wie das von innen aussieht ist
eigentlich relativ egal
aber sonst würde ich eigentlich sagen
dass es bei uns so gut wie jeder sich
jeder hilft mit nicht aktiv aber allein
zum beispiel auch physisch dadurch dass
ich singe zum beispiel machen die das
alles viel schneller aber die wollen
dass ich fertig werde mit senken spaß
also planung jeder hilft halt irgendwie
so ein bisschen mit sag ich mal durch
bestimmte organische gibt es gedenken
kein klarer sieger quatscht beider
gruppen das lasse ich eigentlich hab
nicht mal bio
naja jedenfalls haben jetzt die erste
seite vom
niemand wird nach erkennen dass dies ein
schneemann ist
www wir werden bestimmt ihnen eine
person finden die das erkennt bestimmt
hoffentlich vielleicht gar nicht
der baum ist entdeckt definitiv weg die
ruckelt das gerade ganz schön und zwar
während ihr diese folge seiner letzten
folge sagt bin ich gerade in weimar und
dort sieht es ungefähr genauso aus wie
hier einfach nur weiß alles voller
schnee die temperaturen wenn wir da sind
sind bei minus sechs grad
was ich nehmen was gerade am fünften
hier auf diese folge und ja da muss es
auf jeden fall dann also ich fahre
morgen am sechsten und heute also wenn
diese folge sieht dass der rat die
siebte folge
das heißt ich bin dann schon da und ja
das problem ist halt einfach nur dass es
kalt wird und wir mal überhaupt keinen
bock darauf dass es so kalt wird weil
wir wer wir besichtigen da das kz und
goethe haus und alles mögliche
zurück zum thema weihnachtsbaum
schmücken ist kann hier eine story zu
erzählen und zwar damals der
weihnachtskrippe bei uns gekauft von
apps oder so
die sache ist einfach die gewesen war
echt jedenfalls der fußball interessiert
ist kann sich an fifa das war mein
klingelton falls das gehört habt ich hab
so einen geilen klingelton ohne witz ich
habe dieses baby geliebt von campus
bildes zucker er wird wahrscheinlich
noch mal klingeln weil er klingt immer
so alle fünf minuten dann welche
nachricht bekommen habe weil es halt das
komische imessage von iphone ist
irgendwie also bei der krippe und werte
die von ikea und ist dann irgendwann
halt kaputt gegangen kurz vor
weihnachten kurz bevor also werden die
gekauften papa und später ist kaputt
gegangen dann kurz vor weihnachten und
dann wir so hin
von der krippe sind kein christkind sohn
jong un war glaube ich viel wie viele
tag vor weihnachten los drei vier tage
vor weihnachten und da unser opa also
der von meiner schwester und mir also
der vater von meiner mutter so damit ihr
das ist der ist handwerk ich sage ich
mal recht gehabt
okay da hat sich damals man seinen
finger so halb dabei abgeschnitten
na da jetzt kein fingernagel mehr aber
das ist relativ egal weil ich find den
trotzdem cool ist der kunde von beiden
opas findet jedenfalls der handwerklich
recht begabt und hat uns dann so eine
ich sag mal ersatz krippe gemacht und
ich benutzen wir seitdem immer wieder
sah man ihm auch keine neue mehr gekauft
welt die einfach so mega geil ist und
wisst ihr was ich glaube wir wollten das
komplette dings hier auf die nächste
folge auch noch mit aus wald ich mach
das mal kommt und schon muss jetzt von
immer noch schön aussehen und zwar denke
ich dass das ihr schneemann teil eins
sein wird und an teil 2 werde ich
darüber ein bisschen weiter quatschen
über das thema und das wird dann auch
dann okay gut dann würde ich das mal
sagen weil ich möchte folgt nicht so
lange machen weil ich muss ja noch alles
irgendwie vor einmal hoch landet das
schaffe ich das nicht hinbekommt hier
keine folgen und ja sehe ich schon
wieder bei nahezu neun minuten
wir sind bei einer minuten so sieht es
der schneemann aus und ich merke schon
der weg immens groß mit größer als
dieser kleine fusion und damit ich sagen
ja
bei der letzten folge bzw bei einer der
letzten folgen habe ich mal gesagt dass
wir 400 nach ich sag's ein klingelton
dass wir 400 likes für diese
sternschnuppen gehen wir hinkriegen oder
eine 400 experten adventskranz was
glaube ich und da hat crash der eiskalt
1200 likes dreimal so viele
das richtig krass was mit euch los ist
also wirklich richtig froh dass ich euch
ab sondern community und dann würde ich
sagen
schaffen wir heute
ich bin mir nicht sicher schafft 900
daumen hoch für diese dieses quadrat
also morgen geht es weiter mit dem
schneemann das ist dann diesmal
schlimmer und ein einzel morgen kommt
das thema teil 2 wäre ich da mal wieder
schaffen würden und dann würde ich sagen
schreibt mir weiterhin themen
geschichten kommentare etc
ja in die kommentare facebook twitter
ist in der beschreibung wo immer auf dem
neuesten stand der facebook könnt ihr
übrigens auch geschichte schreiben dort
lese ich die sogar teilweise ein
bisschen öfter und dann will ich sagen
sie mit 19